what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like our
good old friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man is sticking around in the MCU
for at least a few more years and it
looks like Tom Holland is about to sign
on for several more projects not just
Spider-Man projects but of course big
team up films as well this is obviously
amazing news but what's even cooler is
it looks like Tom Holland is not only
going to sign a contract to remain in
the MCU but could even possibly be
appearing in the Sony spider-verse even
more than he had before which is really
nothing yes they kind of connected
Spider-Man no way home with the Sony
universes because Andrew Garfield and
Toby Maguire they both came from their
universes which are technically Sony
universes and it does look like we'll be
seeing the three of them back on the big
screen again separately but also
together both in the MCU and possibly in
the Sony spiderverse as well because
although we do have new reports today
for Tom Holland's contract with the MCU
we also have been getting reports lately
and and in the past about Sony wanting
to keep Angie Garfield and Toby Maguire
around for their Sony spiderverse as
well and of course let's not forget the
fact that we still could possibly be
getting the Amazing Spider-Man 3. we'll
talk about all of this in this video and
of course if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the videos so first and
foremost let's talk about Tom Holland's
new Spider-Man contract between Sony and
Marvel studioslash Disney it looks like
the deal is pretty close to coming to an
end which makes sense because Spider-Man
4 isn't too far away in the MCU plus not
to mention Avengers the Kang Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars aren't too far away
either and to top that off Daredevil
isn't that far away and apparently
Spider-Man 4 is going to tackle some of
the events that took place in Daredevil
we are assuming Kingpin that makes the
most sense but once the Daredevil series
comes out we'll have a little bit better
of an idea but Spider-Man 4 right now
has an unofficial release date of July
of 2 2024 that's a little bit over a
year and a half away that means they
really have to get everything done for
Spider-Man 4 pretty quickly because it
takes at least a full year for filming
pre-production production everything
involved in making a movie It Takes a
good amount of time over a year so I'm
expecting this contract to be completely
finalized within the next couple of
months at the very latest but based off
of the news that we are hearing today
Tom Holland's contract with Marvel and
Sony is pretty much done but there does
seem to be a bit of misinformation going
around out there so let's clear that up
here's what happened yesterday and today
in a tweet by The Cosmic circuses Lizzie
Hill she tweeted a gift of Tom Holland
saying that's right I'm Spider-Man then
she quote tweeted it saying she hopes
that Tom Holland is having a great day
and at the end of the sentence she put a
winky face emoji noting that something
was definitely going on most likely the
fact that Tom Holland has probably
signed a new deal to play Spider-Man
again then the Insider account culture
underscore spider gave credit to Lizzie
Hill stating Lizzie knew it was coming
and was first to hint at it you all know
she's a bad a and to make sure that it
was super clear culture underscore
spider tweeted saying new Tom Holland
deal coming right up but here's where
things got a little bit interesting
somebody tweeted the details of Tom
Holland's new Spider-Man deal Daredevil
Born Again Spider-Man 4 the King Dynasty
Secret Wars Spider-Man 5 Spider-Man 6.
in this tweet the same account at good
CBM takes also stated Zendaya and Jacob
have not signed anything yet now we
don't really know anything about this
account so take what they said with a
grain of salt but what's interesting is
that Alex P from the cosmic circus
replied to this tweet stating Holland's
contract does not feature Disney plus
appearances I'm being told so if any and
this is in quotes deal end quote out
there includes an appearance in a Disney
Plus show chances are it isn't real so
if that remains to be be true then
Spider-Man most likely isn't making a
cameo appearance in Daredevil born again
because that would be a Disney Plus show
so if this information is accurate No
Disney Plus shows no Daredevil however
the same is not true for the opposite of
that Daredevil could very well appear in
Spider-Man 4. especially if you consider
the fact that the street level Avengers
team is being assembled right now in the
MCU and that's most likely what
Spider-Man 4 is going to be about Peter
Parker's new life with him on his own
sadly no more Aunt May no more happy no
more Iron Man and no more MJ or Ned but
hopefully he will find new friends and
other superheroes like Daredevil and
whoever else appears in New York City
but the contract that Tom Holland is
signing for the MCU does most likely
include these five projects Spider-Man 4
5 and 6 that's a new Trilogy and then of
course the two Avengers films the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars but he could
also appear in the Sony Spider-Man
universe like I mentioned and we'll talk
talk about that in just a bit but first
a big thank you to wondery and the
official Lord of the Rings rings of
power podcast for sponsoring this video
now I know a lot of you like me have
watched The Lord of the Rings the rings
of power on Amazon it's amazing I loved
it and since you're on my Channel right
now you probably love to dive even
deeper than just watching the show and
now you can go deeper into the canals of
numenor the minds of kazadum and more
with the official the Lord of the Rings
rings of power podcast host Felicia Day
who many people probably know and
several special guests provide an inside
look at the groundbreaking series and
what it took to bring Middle Earth to
life each episode of the official
podcast features exclusive interviews
with the series showrunner DJ Payne and
Patrick McKay including the very first
full breakdown of the incredible season
finale Felicia also goes behind the
scenes with the cast and crew to bring
you jaw-dropping stories and Easter eggs
you won't want to miss watch the rings
of power on Prime video and listen to
all eight episodes of the official the
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast for free on Amazon music
download the Amazon music app right now
to listen to The Lord of the Rings the
rings of power podcast so a lot of
people are taking this information as
Tom Holland officially securing a new
contract to play Spider-Man which is
fantastic news but like I mentioned he
might not actually be alone for all of
these projects as we've also gotten
reports in the past from insiders that
Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire could
have possibly both signed deals to
appear in Avengers Secret Wars now of
course this makes perfect sense Secret
Wars is going to be about universes
colliding into each other the Multiverse
essentially becoming just one universe
so we're going to see a bunch of
different variants of a ton of
characters that we know and love
Spider-Man is going to be one of them
and since we've already seen these two
variants it makes sense that they would
show up again but here's the really cool
thing Sony is also kind of building
their own Multiverse as well and we
could also see R3 Spider-Man reunite in
that Universe too if you've been
following following the channel or
Spider-Man news in general you know that
it looks like Sony is building up to a
huge spider-verse Multiverse movie and
that is the story of spider-geden and
yes that name is a play on Armageddon
essentially where the world comes to an
end except for in our case it's spider
gennan and it's a movie filled with a
bunch of different Spider-Man variants
and when I say a bunch I'm not talking
about three four or five I'm talking
about over 15. at least in the comics
there are over 15 variants that appear
in the same story in the same universe
this will most likely take place after
Avengers Secret Wars but it is another
opportunity to see R3 Spider-Man on
screen at the same time together again
and leading up to that we could
definitely be seeing Andrew Garfield's
and Toby Maguire Spider-Man Sony is
securing or has secured their contract
with Tom Holland but old rumors suggest
that they have also talked to Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire about
reappearing in the Sony spider-verse and
with the recent success of Spider-Man no
way home insiders state that they are
considering making The Amazing
Spider-Man 3 Within Garfield and Andrew
has already expressed that he is
interested although he did say that he
wished people would have spoken up
before in the past so Andrew could get
another movie by himself his own solo
The Amazing Spider-Man 3 movie whereas
what we've heard about Toby Maguire is
that he could pop up in other films not
necessarily getting his own movie like
Spider-Man 4 but simply jumping on into
others but hey that gets him back into
the Sony spider-verse even if it isn't
his own film he could still interact
with Andrew Garfield Spider-Man with Tom
Hollands with Venom and anybody else
that they may be bringing in soon so the
future of Spider-Man Spider-Man is
really really bright it looks like Tom
Holland is going to be our Spider-Man in
the MCU for at least five more projects
so let me know how excited you are about
this in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest MCU
and Spider-Man news and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof